>> Laura: WE HAVE THE FBI
RAIDING THE PRESIDENT'S LAWYER'S
OFFICE TO FIND STORMY DANIELS
DOCUMENTS.
OUR NEXT GUEST IS SPEARHEADING
THE EFFORT TO FIND OUT WHY THE
DEPARTMENT OF JUSTICE OPEN THE
RUSSIAN INCLUSION PROBE IN THE
FIRST PLACE.
SURPRISE, SURPRISE.
THE DOJ WON'T GIVE US STRAIGHT
ANSWERS.
JOINING ME NOW EXCLUSIVELY,
HOUSE INTEL COMMITTEE CHAIRMAN
DEVIN NUNES, A REPUBLICAN FROM
CALIFORNIA.
CONGRESSMAN NUNES, THANKS FOR
COMING ON.
YOU'VE BEEN TRYING TO GET
DOCUMENTS FOR AS LONG AS I'VE
BEEN DOING THE SHOW.
THAT'S ALL YOU DO IS TRY TO GET
DOCUMENTS.
PEOPLE HAVE BEEN ASKING WHY IS
IT THAT YOU HAVEN'T YET HELD
ANYONE IN CONTEMPT OF CONGRESS.
THAT'S A BIG DEAL TO DO THAT.
ERIC HOLDER WAS HELD IN CONTEMPT
OF CONGRESS, AS I RECALL, OVER
THE FAST AND FURIOUS DOCUMENTS.
WHAT GIVES HERE?
>> IT'S TRICKLE-DOWN DOCUMENTS.
WE ISSUED THE SUBPOENA IN
AUGUST.
PIECE BY PIECE, EVERY TIME WE
GET A LITTLE BIT MORE.
AS YOU KNOW, WE HAD TO GET OUT
THE MAJOR INFORMATION WHICH WAS
THE INFORMATION ON THE WARRANT
AGAINST CARTER PAGE WAS A TRUMP
ASSOCIATE.
SINCE THAT TIME, WE'VE BEEN
INVESTIGATING THE
STATE DEPARTMENT AND WE HAVE AN
INTEREST IN THIS ELECTRONIC
COMMUNICATION.
>> Laura: THE DOCUMENT THAT
ESTABLISHES THAT JUSTIFICATION
FOR ULTIMATELY NAMING THE
SPECIAL COUNSEL.
THIS WHOLE THING ENDED UP.
>> OPENED THE
COUNTERINTELLIGENCE
INVESTIGATION.
>> Laura: INITIALLY THAT
ULTIMATELY LED TO THE SPECIAL
COUNSEL.
>> IT'S A TWO PAGE DOCUMENT.
I SENT CHAIRMAN GOWDY TO SEE IT.
IT WAS FULLY REDACTED.
I CALLED BACK SEVERAL TIMES, HAD
CONVERSATIONS WITH ROD
ROSENSTEIN AND FBI DIRECTOR
WRAY.
THERE WAS A FEW MORE THINGS
UNREDACTED.
MOST OF IT WAS STILL REDACTED.
NOW WE ARE AT THIS POINT AGAIN
WHERE THE BOILING POINT WHERE WE
NEED THIS.
WHAT'S ONLY A TWO PAGE DOCUMENT.
IT'S ONLY TWO PAGES.
IT'S LESS THAN TWO PAGES, FROM
WHAT I UNDERSTAND.
IF THE RECORD WASN'T THAT EVERY
TIME THEY HIDE SOMETHING FROM
US, THAT THAT WHEN WE FIND OUT
IT WAS BAD AND THEY HIT IT FROM
US.
>> Laura: LIKE THE JUDGE
CONTRERA ISSUE.
THE TRICKLE DOWN INFORMATION.
OH, NO, THAT'S WHY YOU REDACTED.
>> THEY ARE NOT GIVING THIS TO
US AND IT TELLS ME THERE
SOMETHING WRONG.
>> Laura: ROBERT COSTA FROM
"THE WASHINGTON POST" IS
SPECULATING TONIGHT ON TWITTER
THAT YOU ARE ON THE VERGE OF
MOVING TO HOLD CHRISTOPHER WRAY
AND ROD ROSENSTEIN IN CONTEMPT
OF CONGRESS.
WE HAVE A DEADLINE OF TOMORROW
APPARENTLY.
IS THIS A REAL POSSIBILITY?
>> I CAN TELL YOU WE ARE GOING
TO GET THE DOCUMENTS.
WE ARE GOING TO GET THE TWO
PAGES.
THEY CAN EITHER COUGH THEM UP
NOW OR IT WILL GET REALLY
COMPLICATED STARTING TOMORROW
NIGHT AND WE WILL HAVE TO TAKE
ALL THE STEPS NECESSARY IN ORDER
TO GET THE DOCUMENTS.
>> Laura: WHAT ARE YOU
THINKING MIGHT BE IN THEM?
>> HERE'S --
>> HERE'S OUR CHALLENGE WITH
THIS.
IF YOU BELIEVE WHAT'S IN
"THE NEW YORK TIMES" AND
"WASHINGTON POST," SOMETIMES
THEY ACTUALLY DO GET LEAKED
INFORMATION.
IN THE INFORMATION THAT CAME OUT
IN DECEMBER WAS THE INFORMATION
ON AN AUSTRALIAN DIPLOMAT
TALKING TO MR. PAPADOPOULOS.
THAT'S WHAT THEY SAY IS IN THE
EC.
WE HAVEN'T BEEN ABLE TO SEE THE
EC TO CONFIRM IT.
SOMEHOW THE MARITIMES HAS IT BUT
THE U.S. CONGRESS DOES NOT HAVE
THE INFORMATION.
>> Laura: ARE YOU DISTURBED BY
THESE LEAKS THAT SEEM TO BE
EMANATING FROM THAT SPECIAL
COUNSEL'S OFFICE ABOUT THE
INTENT OF WHAT THE RAID ON THE
COHEN OFFICE WAS, WHAT THEY WERE
REALLY LOOKING FOR, WHAT THEY
ARE SPECULATING.
THERE'S A LOT OF INFORMATION
THAT CAME OUT YESTERDAY.
>> THE BIGGER PROBLEM, THE
SPECIAL COUNSEL I WOULD'VE
THOUGHT WOULD'VE GOTTEN TO THE
FELONY LEAKS OF GENERAL FLYNN'S
NAME BEING LEAKED TO THE PRESS
WITH HIGH-LEVEL INFORMATION.
SEEMS LIKE THE SPECIAL COUNSEL
IS GOOD AT LEAKING BUT NOT SO
GOOD IT ACTUALLY FINDING MAJOR
FELONY LEAKERS.
>> Laura: WHAT ARE THE CHANCES
YOU ARE GOING TO HOLD THEM IN
CONTEMPT OF CONGRESS RIGHT NOW?
>> WE ARE NOT GOING TO JUST HOLD
THEM IN CONTEMPT.
WE HAVE A PLAN TO HOLD IN
CONTEMPT AND IMPEACH.
>> Laura: IMPEACH CHRISTOPHER
WRAY?
>> ABSOLUTELY.
WE ARE NOT MESSING AROUND.
>> Laura: THEY ARE GOING TO
SAY THAT YOU ARE TRUMP'S LACKEY.
THE DEMOCRATS HAVE BEEN
DEMONIZING YOU FROM THE
BEGINNING.
I'VE BEEN THE SUBJECT OF
DEMONIZATION MYSELF SO I KNOW
HOW GOES.
THEY ARE GOING TO DEMONIZE YOU.
>> WELCOME AS I SAID BEFORE,
WHENEVER I SEE EVIDENCE OF
RUSSIAN INCLUSION, I'LL BE THE
FIRST PERSON STANDING OUT THERE
ON THE STEPS OF THE CAPITAL THAT
I FOUND THE RUSSIAN COLLISION
WITH THE TRUMP CAMPAIGN.
I HAVEN'T FOUND IT YET BUT I
HAVE FOUND A WHOLE LOT OF OTHER
STUFF THAT PUTS DOJ AND FBI IN A
BAD LIGHT.
>> Laura: OTHER MEDIA CHANNELS
ARE SALIVATING TONIGHT IN A
FROTHY FRENZY OVER ONCE AGAIN,
TRUMP IS GOING TO FIRE ROBERT
MUELLER.
SARAH HUCKABEE SANDERS WAS ASKED
ABOUT THIS TODAY.
>> ROD ROSENSTEIN OVERSEE
SPECIAL COUNSEL AND ONLY HE HAS
THE POWER TO FIRE THE SPECIAL
COUNSEL.
>> AGAIN, WE'VE BEEN ADVISED
THAT THE PRESIDENT HAS THE POWER
TO MAKE THAT DECISION.
>> Laura: I DON'T THINK
THERE'S ANY SIGN TRUMP IS REALLY
GOING TO FIRE MUELLER BUT
REPUBLICANS ARE FREAKING OUT
ABOUT IT AS WELL.
>> THEY SAID THIS BEFORE.
>> Laura: HE HAS THE
AUTHORITY.
>> THEY SAID HE WAS FIRING ALL
KINDS OF PEOPLE AND IT NEVER
CAME TO FRUITION.
>> Laura: THIS IS WHAT HE
SAID.
>> THE REGULATION IS CLEAR.
IT SAYS SPECIAL COUNSEL MAY BE
DISCIPLINED OR REMOVED FROM
OFFICE ONLY BY THE PERSONAL
ACTION OF THE ATTORNEY GENERAL.
HE MAY REMOVE THE SPECIAL
COUNSEL FOR NUMBER OF REASONS.
DERELICTION OF DUTY, INCAPACITY.
HAS TO PROVIDE REASONS IN
WRITING.
IT'S VERY CLEAR IF THE PRESIDENT
OF THE UNITED STATES, AS LONG AS
THESE REGULATIONS ARE IN EFFECT,
CALLS UP BOB MUELLER AND SAYS
I'M FIRING YOU, I SUSPECT BOB
MUELLER WOULD NOT HEED THAT.
>> Laura: WE HAVE AN EXECUTIVE
BRANCH, JUDICIAL BRANCH,
LEGISLATIVE BRANCH.
IN WHICH BRANCH DOES BOB MUELLER
RESIDE?
THE EXECUTIVE BRANCH.
AGAIN, I THINK IT WOULD NOT BE
SMART AT ALL FOR THE PRESIDENT
TO FIRE BOB MUELLER.
I DO NOT THINK IT MAKES SENSE.
AS TEMPTING AS IT MAY BE, I
DON'T THINK IT MAKES SENSE.
THE IDEA THAT HE DOESN'T HAVE
THE CONSTITUTIONAL AUTHORITY TO
DO THAT.
BERRA >> THIS IS HOW FAR WE'VE G
BERRA >> THIS IS HOW FAR WE'VE N
BERRA >> THIS IS HOW FAR WE'VE E
DOWN IN THE LAST EIGHT OR NINE
YEARS WHERE COURTS HAVE BECOME
ACTIVIST COURTS, ACTIVIST
JUDGES.
THE FACT THE DOJ AND FBI THINK
THEY ARE ABOVE THE LAW.
CONGRESS, THE LEGISLATIVE
BRANCH, WE CREATED THESE
AGENCIES.
THEY HAVE THE RESPONSIBILITY TO
GIVE US DOCUMENTS WHEN WE ASK.
WE HAVE THE APPROPRIATE
CLEARANCES.
THAT'S WHY THE HOUSE
INTELLIGENCE COMMITTEE EXISTS.
AT THE END OF THE DAY, WE ARE
GOING TO WIN ON THIS.
IT'S JUST A MATTER OF HOW TOUGH
THEY ARE GOING TO MAKE IT FOR
CONGRESS TO ACTUALLY DO OUR JOB.
UNDER THE CONSTITUTION AND THE
PRIORITIES WE ARE GIVEN.
>> Laura: TO HOLD SOMEONE IN
CONTEMPT OF CONGRESS, I DON'T
KNOW THE PROCESS.
YOU ARE THE HEAD OF THE INTEL
COMMITTEE.
DO YOU NEED TO HAVE SIGNOFF FROM
OTHERS IN THE INTEL COMMITTEE?
>> ULTIMATELY MEMBERS HAVE TO
VOTE ON IT.
>> Laura: WHAT'S THE CHANCES?
>> I DON'T THINK WE ARE GOING TO
HAVE TO GET THERE.
I THINK THEY ARE GOING TO GIVE
US THE DOCUMENTS.
>> Laura: WE ARE GOING TO